for ages
neil wanted to recreate one of his very
first experiments
and it involves aluminium tops
from milk bottles so i have been
collecting
for months milk bottle tops
and just today i managed to get them to
kneel
in the lab the chemistry behind this
is that aluminium can react not only
with acids
but with alkalis it's a so-called
amphoteric
material it can react with acids to form
salt
like hydrochloric acid to make aluminium
chloride
it can react with sodium hydroxide
which is what neil was going to use to
make sodium
illuminate
what neil did was to take some of my
milk bottle tops
and put them into a flask when he did
the reaction
as a boy he used a milk bottle
but unfortunately the design of milk
bottles have changed
and the balloon that is a crucial part
of this experiment
won't fit over the neck of a modern
bottle
so once the bottle tops are in the
bottle
the next thing is to make the sodium
hydroxide solution
and sodium hydroxide dissolves in water
releasing a huge amount of heat
so he mixed and made very concentrated
solution
and you can see the solution getting
really very hot
in fact neil got a bit worried that this
was going to be
a bit too strong and potent so he put a
little water in with the milk bottles
tops
just to calm things down but then
the flask had a glass stopper
and at the end of the tube of the glass
stopper there was a pink balloon
so he poured in the sodium hydroxide
solution
and then quickly put in the stopper with
the balloon
and the balloon inflated at a huge rate
got really quite worried
it's fast that's going to pop and it was
filling
also he believed with hydrogen you know
hydrogen is much lighter than air
and before the balloon could burst he
took it off
and tied it in a knot so he had a
hydrogen balloon
but the flask kept on
reacting a bit like the sorcerer's
apprentice
things started flying out of the top
and neil got really worried
about brady's cameras all round the
flask
would they dissolve in the sodium
hydroxide but
he'd really demonstrated this was a good
reaction
then he thought it would be nice to show
that the balloon contained hydrogen
that moment came a big surprise because
when he
tried to let go of the balloon
instead of shooting upwards as you would
expect with a hydrogen balloon
it fell to the floor what had happened
he was really worried but being real he
thought
just in case he would put a match to the
balloon
and when he did even though it was on
the floor
it went off with a really satisfying
explosion
now of course the balloon's blown up but
what i think happened
was that the gas came out of the flask
so quickly
that he actually filled the balloon with
a mixture of air
and hydrogen so when he
tied it off it wasn't lighter than air
because it contained
hydrogen and air together and of course
there's the weight of the rubber of the
balloon
but then when he let it off
it burnt much better than it would have
done if it was just hydrogen
and i think the clue is in the fact that
the flame
that was formed was a much whiter orange
color
than when you normally let off a
hydrogen balloon
which tends to be rather red neil was
really
satisfied
he could still do the things he did when
he was young
because it's an old sample but let's
have a look
are you ready go